bonjour tout le monde je commence par
une question pour vous combien d'entre
vous connaissez quelqu'un qui a reçu un
diagnostic de cancer tout le monde ça me
surprend pas parce que comme arrêté au
début à tout les onze minutes un
québécois reçu un diagnostic de cancer
et ça malgré les milliards de dollars
investis
mais ce qui est pire c'est que les gens
atteints de cancer sont de plus en plus
jeunes et malgré la science la médecine
c'est que aujourd'hui on encore jusqu'à
option pour se soigner en cancérologie
là surgit la chimiothérapie
l'hormonothérapie et la radiothérapie
une seule médecin est rarement on nous
parle d'alimentation
pourtant il n'ya pas juste une vérité en
cancérologie
mais plutôt une stratégie a développé à
l'aide de la médecine intégrative et
l'importance du mode de vie
j'ai eu un parcours très atypique parce
que j'ai fait affaire avec la médecine
intégrative c'est un mélange de médecine
allopathique et de la médecine
alternative une union pourtant qui tire
la pâte au québec par rapport au reste
du canada et des états unis
tellement que présentement depuis juin
je fais partie d'un consortium
international appelé de metabolic cannes
sur groupe composé de 24 chercheurs et
médecins dont nous mettons à profit nos
connaissances
et nos expériences dans le but de
diffuser le plus d'informations possible
aux personnes atteintes de cancer et à
la population générale
donc tout a débuté pour moi en 1993 un
autre que j'ai reçu un diagnostic de
cancer car sinon médullaire la thyroïde
à ce moment là j'ai reçu le choc
stoïquement j'ai pas pleurer j'y reviens
des médecins qui j'ai dit je mourrai pas
de trop vous allez faire votre job je
vois faire la mienne puis regardez moi
bien mais il la regarda l'est encore
aujourd'hui
et puis là après la première chirurgie
qui a duré 10 heures
mais on ne donnait que quelques mois à
vivre étant donné l'étendue de la
maladie parce que ça va puis 5 1 avant
que je reçoive le diagnostic huit ans
plus tard et cinq chirurgies à mon actif
mon chirurgien na vi qui a atteint sa
limite et que je ne suis plus au père un
bon ben moi je n'avais pas atteint ma
limite puis j'allais vivre envers et
contre tout parce que je me suis dit il
faut que je me prenne en main parce que
de toute façon mon corps lui on pouvait
plus de l'attak du scalpel 1 puis je dis
souvent en face qu'à 20 chirurgie
mesurer 5 et 4 mètres sur 5 et 2
donc ma seule planche de salut a été de
me prendre en main et de faire des
recherches et de me poser plusieurs
questions mes recherches m'ont amené à
lire sur la restriction calorique sur la
diète 70 jeunes
j'avais lu sur l'institut est pas crêpes
j'ai lu c'est sur le livre du docteur
richard béliveau les aliments anticancer
mais s'était passé donc vous vous doutez
bien que mc est mené bien loin des
discours conventionnel
ma première destination a été instituée
par crainte en floride un centre
d'alimentation vivante alimentation crue
végétalienne mais je dirais c'est plutôt
un centre d'éducation à la santé
je me suis dit si la santé ça s'apprend
mais la maladie ça se comprend mais
écoutez j'ai passé trois ans même labo
enrichissante à comprendre
l'intelligence du corps humain et sa
capacité de billets exemple j'ai appris
à cultiver ma santé doit renfermer santé
j'en suis revenu après générer et
surtout je vous dirais que ça a été ma
première appelle scientifique
j'avais la piqûre roche devant savoir
plus
j'ai fait ni une ni deux je me suis
inscrite à une formation de 80
naturopathie en plus de prendre la
formation d'éducateurs à la santé
l'institut ipr crack en floride et j'ai
fait bien d'autres choses
ce qui m'a amené un rapport sur des
maquettes
je suis retourné à hippocrate en 2007
pour faire un stage de deux mois et le
directeur m'a présenté le docteur
georges joue qui est un neurologue
américain qui fait de la recherche dans
le cadre des baisses qui cerise pour les
national institutes of et f des états
unis parce que pour lui
l'alimentation est le pilier dans toute
approche visant à traiter le cancer
ben je vous dirais que c'est à partir de
cet instant que pour moi la science dans
son assiette
j'écoute pas le médicament a pris toute
son importance
puis concoules à un diagnostic aussi
catastrophique peut devenir un tremplin
vers un changement de mode de vie
changement car et un changement conjoint
changement aurait là donc ça c'est les
directeurs d'instituts pas grave donc
par la suite on s'est mis à travailler
ensemble dr ue et moi et on a entrepris
un projet de recherche sur le cancer du
sein et mélanome cancer de peau avec
l'institut avait excusé la l'université
de californie sur l'impact de la
restriction calorique sur la régression
des cellules cancéreuses et nous devions
loger nos candidates pourra trouver un
laboratoire in vivo
donc on a trouvé deux instituts
évidemment instituée par grant en
floride
le centre d'alimentation végétalien cru
qui existe depuis 60 ans et nous les
avons amenés également à l'institut
kuchi de bostens une institut
d'alimentation macrobiotique créé par
michaud cauchy un japonais
donc les deux instituts ont une
alimentation diamétralement opposées
mais des résultats similaires
ça va me dire pourquoi le dénominateur
commun est la restriction calorique
c'est une alimentation à haute valeur
nutritive
mais qui fournit de 1200 à 1800 calories
par jour en plus des combinaisons
alimentaires
donc on sait qu'avec la restriction
calorique et les nombreuses recherches
que un tiers des patients auront une
rémission complète et deux tiers auront
une amélioration temporaire
d'où la nécessité d'ajouter d'autres
thérapies alternatives ce que je fais
pour moi depuis 14 ans et ma clientèle à
présent on a eu des questionnements
il nous manquait
d'autres points de compréhension c'est à
ce moment que fait le professeur thomas
ses fruits qui entrent en jeu dans notre
équipe il est l'auteur du livre cannes
ce réseau métabolique des is so ça a été
tout un changement de paradigme dans le
monde médical car ils affluent et tenez
vous bien que 5 à 10% des cancers sont
génétiques
tout le reste des cancers confondus sont
une maladie métabolique sa part des
travaux dot award en 1935
c'est que c'est une mauvaise respiration
séduirait une fermentation et une
mauvaise captation du sucre en bref l'on
sait que la cellule cancéreuse
c'est une baby tu as eu pilote pour vous
montrer sol ici c'est l'image d'un petit
canot tomographie par émission de
positrons et des points oranges
ce sont des cellules cancéreuses qui ont
capté le sucre parce qu'ils nous injecte
fdg donc à partir de tout ça on sait
aujourd'hui avec la multitude de
recherche de produits scientifiques sur
l'alimentation que nous devons plus que
jamais changé notre alimentation changer
notre alimentation peut changer le cours
de la maladie et même des gens en 1901
en viron thomas edison a dit que le
médecin du futur ne traite pas ni ne
préviendra la maladie avec la médication
mais bien avec l'alimentation mais y
avait peut-être une boule de cristal
mais moi je sais pertinemment que changé
mon alimentation
c'est je préférais l'attaquent de la
fourchette dans mon assiette que l'attak
du bistouri d'un monde parce que
personnellement je sais également que la
santé et le bien le plus précieux que
nous ayons
et celui dont on s'occupe le moins pour
moi dans mon cheminement des 22
dernières années je me suis prise en
main j'ai gardé mon pouvoir
j'ai fait mes propres recherches et
surtout je me suis mais je me suis aimé
assez pour changer changer c'est bon
pour la santé
la vase curative des animaux a été
bénéfique pour moi embarqué dans la
danse et vous taisez merci